foreign
I'm just not kind to him and I don't
know how to stop because I don't see
that I'm doing it until after I've done
it husbands across the country are
cheering as they're listening to this
[Music]
what's up what's up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show show where we
talk about your marriage or your mental
health or boundaries hard decisions
you've got to make dealing with kids
whatever's going on in your life when it
comes to your relationships your mental
health to what's going on with your kids
schools all
we've entered into this Vortex where
there's experts on every corner yelling
and screaming very few people are
telling the truth anymore and there's
just so much chaos and so much noise and
I spent the first I don't know
a long time I tried to disappear from
the internet I didn't want to
participate in any of this I want it out
and I had a counseling Professor who put
her finger in my chest and she said you
don't get to do that you don't get to
walk away
you got to get involved and I didn't
know involvement was going to be hosting
a podcast and doing everything on the
internet but here we are um and with the
YouTube show all of it so there's my
promise I'm gonna cut through the noise
I'm gonna sit with you and we're gonna
figure it out what whatever's going on
in your life and we're gonna get you to
the help that you need or help you to
the next right step if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and pre-sale for building a
non-inxious life is live I'm super hyped
about this book
um do you see the seat up there I'm
gonna see if Nate Dogg can can point up
to it for the YouTube gang it's up there
you can see it
um look at that look at that fancy book
where'd it go Nate Dogg that was some
that was some caramel work right there
hey um
I was talking to our team this morning
we have about a thousand people to work
here and at the company and I was
talking to team this morning
I just let them know hey this this book
um
this book broke me this book
caused me to look in the mirror in the
way that I haven't
um ever and to say some things out loud
with a therapist and with my with my
people that I care about and love that
I've never said before and
um
to really dig into what's the idea what
what are we what about doing here and
more importantly
what does a non-inxious life look like
what's the point
and um
it's been a transformative year to say
the least
um and from everything from
physiological metrics to heart rate
metrics to my daughter that I can't get
from hugging me anymore which is just
making me smile right now
um to a better marriage to just all
everything everything every aspect is
everything perfect absolutely not are
things coming sideways yes have I been
pissed off yes
and I'm not anxious about it I'm not
chronically stressed about I'm not
burned out
check this book out 20 bucks building a
non-anxious life it comes with some
stuff and we're gonna keep add stuff as
we go but go to John deloney.com and
check it out hey before we go to the
call Kelly
top five dude I know look at us ah no
The Little Engine That Could we're like
legit all these 17 listeners man they
are refreshing like a bunch of games God
bless the 17. the OG 17 we uh the the
rankings came out the other day and
we're number four
um and it's pretty exciting stuff man
we're pretty hyped uh four in uh was a
health and fitness I don't know what the
categories are but pretty exciting stuff
dude it's awesome
um that's all I'll say about that oh and
hey and my friend Sean Ryan his show
went to number two on the big boy list
it's like Rogan and the Sean Ryan Show
and he's guy down the street from me I'm
super proud of him the former Navy SEAL
and uh he's just he's he's doing an
amazing job with his show too all right
let's go out to um Danny in Los Angeles
California what's up Danny
all right
yeah I'm all right I'm just super
nervous and then I listen to your show
and people were like I'm so nervous and
I'm like oh my gosh get over it and now
I'm super nervous hey well now you've
made me nervous now this whole thing's
just gonna be a jittery no it's all good
what's up what's up
I just wrote to you because
um I don't know I'm like a horrible wife
and I don't want to be a horrible life
and I try not to be a horrible wife and
it's like I don't realize I'm being a
horrible wife so I've already like done
it and um yeah I just could use some
insight about that tell me how you're a
horrible wife
like
um I'm just like super dismissive of my
husband and I speak to him like really
like cold and like I don't know I'm just
not kind to him and
I don't I don't know why like
how can I say it like I don't know I'm
just not kind to him like I'm very like
short with him and I don't have a lot of
patience and
even when he's like playful like I'll
think in my mind like you know react be
playful as well and then instead I'll be
like rude and then I won't even see that
I'm being like rude to him until
hindsight I'm like oh crap that was like
really mean and sometimes I even like
crying and like apologize to him you
know and you know he accepts my apology
we've been like friends for literally 18
years but
I feel like it's beating him down he
literally has like some gray hairs now
and then I feel guilty like those are my
gray hairs you know like I did that and
um
I don't know I just don't want to be
that person I feel like I'm sabotaging
my marriage like literally and then I
don't know how to stop because I don't
see that I'm doing it until after I've
done it
number one dude I
husbands across the country are cheering
as they're listening to this
um and here's why here's why after 18
years it's hard to look in the mirror
and say
oh dude what if I'm the problem right
like what if I'm contributing something
significant to this so dude high five to
you way to go Danny
um so
and let's be honest
um you and I could dig into your
backstory for a while that's hard to say
out loud what you just said isn't it
how about that yeah exactly so often
when somebody walks me through a story
like you just did
there are some deep deep roots in that
that type of response
either you grew up in an abusive
situation or a chaotic situation or a
situation where you had to run the show
in some or you were asked to run the
show
tell me about growing up what was it
like
well that's crazy that you said about
running the show because that's
I feel like I have to keep everything
together
um because okay so my dad was an
alcoholic like R.I.P
um but um
yeah he was and I don't know my mom was
just like really like passive about it
she didn't really stop him from being
chaotic like he wasn't like physically
or abusive like that but people like
rage out and just kind of just cause a
really hostile
home environment and my mom was like
really positive she was just like quote
unquote keeping the piece but listen you
are not gonna you were not gonna be her
just just die right you're not going to
be her
right
I'm not gonna yeah but not even not even
just die just like how could you let
someone like be crazy like that you know
and so as a kid I would like literally
go like toe-to-toe with my dad like he
never like hit me or anything crazy but
I'd be like the one arguing like hey
like you can't be screaming like that
like I would literally like be a little
girl like telling my dad like cool it
like you know because he would bring all
that negative energy into the whole and
then my mom would be like no go to your
room we have to keep the peace and it's
like bro there's still listen to her
listen to me
dude sorry no no don't be sorry I'm I'm
I'm I'm proud of you and I'm heartbroken
for you because I got a seven-year-old
little girl right now and I'm just
picturing her having to stand up to me
and it breaks my heart
because that wasn't your job man
that was your dad's job that was your
mom's job and at the same time when you
have that little girl fighting there's
also a huge part of that little girl's
heart
wondering
what is so bad about me and Mom that you
have to be like this
or when dad's seven beers in and he's
sitting on the couch and he's right
there but he's not present and you're
wondering where he is kind of like a dad
staring at a cell phone
and I want you to internalize what I'm
about to tell you your nervous system
this is a part of your wiring
has equated love with that man as a
fight
and so when you lean into love your
husband your body has one path that it
follows and that is fight that is war
and you can tell yourself I'm entering
into a space of love with a guy that I
love the guy that treats me right the
guy that shows up he's goofball of
course but man he's awesome
and you get right at him and then war
begins
am I onto something
yeah yeah for sure
so what you're gonna have to decide to
do and it's nothing short of completely
changing how you interact with the world
sometimes on the show I tell people like
man this is as simple as you guys got to
do this and this
and then it's you can clear this thing
up whatever this thing is for you Danny
this is going to be a radical change of
how you interact with yourself and how
you interact with the world and here's
what's scary about what I'm asking you
to do
this is what kept you alive as a kid
this is what kept your house safe
and I'm asking you to put the Sword and
the shield down and you're gonna feel
totally exposed
and it's gonna feel
terrifying it's gonna feel scary
because the only way your body knows
safe is war
but you said it perfectly and you said
something powerful but I want to I want
to one-up you is that cool oh of course
you said you've been with this guy for
18 years
at this point he's a part of you right
your heart's beat together your lungs
breathe together y'all are y'all are
together
and he knows you and he loves you he
loves how fire you are he loves all that
and you said I feel like I'm beating him
down
can I one-up you on that I feel like
you're drowning my friend Danny
I think you're tired of this too
is that fair
extremely young so I'm gonna tell you
something crazy okay
um our childhoods were different my dad
was an alcoholic but I did have some a
lot of chaos and I did have some some
heavy things
only recently within the past year
have I done some work with a counselor
who knew what they were she was doing
that my body has stopped fighting
everything I'm a pretty peaceful guy I
laugh all the time just a goofball I'm
late to everything just kind of like
making my way through the world right
but I didn't know that my body was going
and churning and fighting all the time
all of the time and I track my heart
rate my heart rate variability has
escalated
significantly my heart's beats per
minute have gone down that's a body that
is no longer at War
can I can I spin the machine up if I
have to you damn right I can but I don't
have to
are you in on that
yes for sure Danny I fall asleep with no
medicine
I just fall asleep because I'm tired at
night
my wife and I went on a long long
vacation recently and a couple days in
we had the obligatory fight and then I
was like I just want to go home but I'm
already here
and we worked it out and we had an
amazing vacation can you imagine that
yeah I I can I thought I did my own way
a lot but why what does that get you it
gets you nothing
just like shame I'm trying like that's
right but listen
that seven-year-old little Danny had to
get her way or somebody got hurt
and so it's not wrong that your body's
wired for that
but the thing that kept you alive as a
kid is going to destroy everything as an
adult
I'm gonna do a couple of things for you
okay
number one I'm gonna send you free of
charge
um both of my books own your past change
your future and I'm gonna send you my
brand new book building a non-anxious
life okay
but you got to promise me you'll
actually read them and I'll send you the
audio books too um that way if you're
not a reader you can just put them in
your headphones and listen oh I love
right
but you gotta work through the exercises
in the back okay at the end of each
chapter that's number one
number two
you have to get a some sort of cheap
Journal okay go to Walmart and get one
go to Walgreens and get one
um get a really fancy one off the
internet I don't care but what you have
to begin doing in real time is you have
to begin challenging those thoughts that
I have to
whenever you say the words I have to
or I have to keep it all together ask
yourself or what or what happens we're
five minutes late we missed the first
quarter
is that worth my marriage
or we the burger place that we want to
eat is full and so we gotta go get
chicken I mean is that is is that it
and so every time you think to yourself
I have to I want you to stop
it's gonna take be an annoying 30 to 60
days doing this you're gonna catch
yourself you're gonna be stunned at how
awful you talk to Danny
because you're mean to her aren't you
you gotta stop
so I want you to reframe this sucker as
I'm not trying to not be a horrible wife
I'm trying to build a life that is at
peace
so that I can love this goofball with
all the love that he's worth
right yes most definitely and like I
don't want to show that to my kids I'm
so blessed to be talking to you because
like my kids are super super little and
um I'm hoping that you know I can get it
together before it can cause like an
issue like in my family so let me let me
tell you this I've talked about this on
the show a lot but I'm gonna tell you
just personally okay and then I'm gonna
let you go and hang on the line and I
want you to uh where to get these books
sent out to you
um I'm an amazing Savant
um and I'm understand that because I'm a
parent I'm saying that because I've been
educator for a long time I gotta really
savant
brilliant little girl she's seven and
I've got a son who's humongous he's very
very tall for his age and my daughter's
very small
and
um
you know this as well as I do that hugs
from your kid are healing they're
therapeutic right and my daughter it was
really when I would pick her up she
would get real rigid this is when she's
five or six we're having full
conversations laughing going fishing
together but I would try to hug her she
would duck and move and Bob and weave
she had a whole system
and I thought something was wrong with
me I thought something was wrong with
her I thought something I didn't know
what the deal was it's so weird my son
will hug anytime he's
super super into hugging and then my
wife mentioned it my counselor mentioned
it I did some reading my daughter's body
had recognized I'm not safe there's some
sort of internal churn internal reactor
it's hot
I never scream into my house I don't
swear in my house I don't hit anybody in
my house but my daughter could feel her
tiny little body could sense that guy's
not safe
and I want to tell you you probably have
one of you've got several kids you got
one of them that's like that and you got
one of them that is super super clingy
does that sound right
well I have one I'm gonna have another
one next week oh wow you're in it now
awesome which one is your other one
um he's two okay is he super super
clingy or is he running around
he's all over the place okay all right
often little kids one of them will feel
like it's their job to make sure Mom and
Dad are okay
I know the other one will try to make
sure that um they don't get near mom and
dad even though they're trapped in the
same house I wanted you to know on the
other side of this on the other side of
healing I can't keep my daughter off me
anymore
she's like a monkey
she curls up in my lap she's on me all
the time
and I can't tell you what a gift it is
and why do I tell you all that not
because I'm special I promise you I
promise you Danny I'm not a mess
I'm telling you that because if you'll
follow the steps especially in building
knowledge of Life you'll follow the
steps in this book if you will walk it
through and choose freedom and find what
places where you can challenge your
thoughts you'll go probably have to see
a counselor man you had a tough tough
grown up with an alcoholic it's tough
you make some of these choices on a
daily basis sometimes a weekly basis
your whole system will slow down
your whole system will stop being so
stressed and anxious and that will allow
you to engage in another way that's not
war that's not fighting
it might be goofy it might be silly
you're still gonna be you you're still
gonna roll your eyes you're still going
to be like oh my gosh
but that edge will be off maybe you
won't be so hateful and not so spiteful
and you won't feel so much Shame about
Danny
here's the deal Danny's been fighting
fights for a long long time it's time to
set down the sword set down the shield
and look at this guy he said I love you
do you love me too
let him love you for a change
and don't nag and don't whine and don't
complain complain slim love you for
change
we'll get there we'll
proud of you Danny this is the moment
when everything changes and on the line
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back
in Virginia and talked to Olivia what's
up Olivia
yes how
hello to you what's up
um nothing thanks for taking my call are
you nervous I can hear it in you
I am okay don't be nervous it's all good
man it's all good all right well um I
wrote in because I found out recently
that someone I went to high school with
um got employed by the high school and
like a counselor job and
um I it was just deeply bothered by it I
feel like there's a lot that people
there don't know about
them and
um I want my kids to go there and I just
I kind of want to you know talk to the
people that I
um am close with at the school about it
but I'm like not really wanting to open
that can of worms so just wanted to know
what I should do how I should deal with
it
so you're pretty Coy with a they
is this a mean girl situation or is this
a guy that hurt you
no it's a girl
um and yeah like we we played Sports
together we
um she's just not a good person what
does that mean um just lying cheating
um just like knows how to fool the
adults when we were in high school and
um
damn
26.
let me just say
I
think God I'm not judged right now on
who I was at 16 and 17 and 18.
like I get that I really do and like I
talk to my parents about this too and
they were like you know people change
but like
I
have mutual friends with this person and
it's just not like I'm sorry but it's
just not and
this is not they're like I I'm sorry
that I am still holding her accountable
for these things but she hasn't changed
and give me some examples of how she
hasn't changed how she's still lying and
cheating and swindling people as an
adult
yeah so like she
um
let me just try to like gather what I
want to say
so she like is very up much into like
the hookup culture and this is a this is
like a religious High School okay she's
um like she gets drunk she uses drugs
not I mean she smokes weed occasionally
um and like just not her morals and the
values of her life don't align to what
this school is about and that's why I
feel like every close adult which is
basically
my parents I told they were like what
like I'm sorry who who let that happen
you know and so I'm just thinking which
I know this is not realistic but like in
15 years if my kids go there how am I
going to deal with that like yeah
uh let's let 15 years the world's gonna
be very different in 15 years I'm afraid
so not afraid I'm excited about
um yeah how do you know
how do you know she does drugs and
drinks and because I know the people she
doesn't with okay
so let's do a couple of things number
one
let's let High School go
just let it go and that's why I'm
calling I'm like I don't care about this
like I have it but you do it's in it's
in you exactly I didn't think I did I
didn't think I did
and then this this brought it all back
up and I'm just like in Ray enraged over
it okay
you're the the enrage part like so let's
take her out of the picture if you heard
that some local faith-based high school
hired somebody that's hooking up and
drinking beers
um
you probably roll your eyes
or are you a small town like can you
believe can you whatever
the rage comes from what happened in
high school
and we can get into that like you are
killing yourself by not letting that go
you've probably heard the old phrase you
are drinking poison hoping that she dies
yeah you know what she hasn't thought
about in a long time you
or any of this stuff that happened
but you do and it causes your heart to
go up it causes your all sorts of
physiological issues here
your heart rate to go up
it's killing you
Let It Go yeah don't hold it back
anymore as the great Frozen says
that's why I'm like I don't know how
though
so
a couple of things number one and we'll
get to the actual issue as an adult
number one
um as a practice I started about a
decade ago um I don't have to do it
hardly at all anymore occasionally but
hardly at all
um
but I literally made a commitment to
myself that I would stop having
imaginary conversations in my head with
other people who are not in the room
yeah
and you you're amazing at it I can tell
and you always win them too don't you
like you drop bombs when you're you have
these fantasies of when you talk to her
and you're gonna Point your finger at
her can you do this and she's gonna be
like oh my gosh you're right I did and
it's gonna feel so awesome
your body doesn't know the difference
and so you spin your body up for war all
the time
and you're never gonna have those
conversations you'll never have that
confrontation and if you do it will not
go anything like you think it's going to
yeah and so I literally would walk
through my house and I would yell out
loud nope
I've heard of people with rubber bands
and they pop them on their wrist I've
heard of people who will like Snap their
fingers anything that will break you out
of that cycle because it's instantaneous
your body wants that hit it's addicted
to that cycle that stress cycle get out
of it
and what you have to do is you have to
catch yourself and it will take a while
but stop with the imaginary
conversations and when high school stuff
comes up just stop
number two you probably need to go talk
to a counselor because there's probably
some stuff that happened in high school
is that fair
yeah some ugly stuff Fair
is there stuff you haven't told people
about
green no it's not that dark it's just
I don't know it just felt so undeserving
you know let me ask you this what do you
do for a living
I'm self-employed
I'm pulling our life it's not about that
it's just no I'm just asking you what do
you like what do you do
we own our own business okay y'all doing
great you love it yeah
okay
can you let her just love her thing too
yeah and it's not so much about
like not wanting happiness I'm not that
bitter it's just that
I just don't think she should be in the
position you know okay that leads me to
number two number two if you know of
somebody who is who is openly violating
the core tenants of a place where they
work
then you have to make a grown-up
decision as to whether I'm going to
report that I'm going to say something
to them I'm gonna bring it up or what
but I want to challenge you to make your
decision and either say something or
make your decision to not say anything
and move on with your life because
you're caught in this gray area and
you're torturing yourself
yeah I agree and that's kind of what I'm
saying like is just moving on fine
because like morally I just feel like
I don't think they asked you yeah you're
right I mean the school didn't like put
out feelers and be like like whenever I
got my job at Belmont they had an open
call right they put it in the paper
here's the finalists they had a um open
like a forum where anybody could come in
right it was open like you got something
to say say it now it's like forever hold
your peace right
yeah that's cool didn't ask you for that
yeah you're right so you're you want to
insert yourself into a situation that
doesn't yeah and that's what I'm saying
I don't feel like it's my place but I
just want to like not be so bothered by
it
I think you want to burn her to the
ground
I I mean it's really not I don't feel
like it's that bad I just I promise you
I really it is
it it is
and I I can't tell you I would let it go
yeah and if there's something going
wrong that's wrong right like and I I
could see myself having a conversation
with an executive somewhere I would have
no problem with that if I felt like my
values and morals were challenged on a
particular situation
letting somebody know hey I need you to
know this about this person I've done
that recently actually
it was a super egregious situation but I
was pretty clear
yeah right and so if you feel like you
need to do that do it just do it
but if you're not gonna do that walk
away
yeah walk away and I want to catch
myself here I said they didn't invite
you into this conversation like you're
inserting yourself in the problem
sometimes good citizens do
they run into the middle of a situation
because they see something that somebody
else doesn't see
I don't want someone a house on fire and
sitting out in the front yard and be
like well they never asked me to come
help them so I'm just going to watch it
burn down don't do that right yeah yeah
so if you know somebody is doing some
unethical or illegal or they're they are
pulling the wool over especially as a
teacher right and as an educator as a
mental health professional as a
counselor for God's sake yeah maybe you
do say something
maybe you go to that person first and
you say hey
this isn't cool
um and you get involved that way that's
cool that's fine
but make your decision and then be done
with it
and I want you to practice over the next
30 60 days I want you to practice when
you start that imaginary conversation
when she's in your head literally say
out loud stop no not doing this I'm
being present where I am
what happened in high school happened in
high school
it was a long as eight years ago
almost a decade ago let it ride and if
there are some hard things you need to
talk about some things that weren't fair
some things that hurt you
grief demands a witness you need to say
those things out loud in front of
somebody who will hear you
okay
so call local counselor
book a couple of sessions
but there's some sort of thing in you
that you had to overcome a lot and
you've got a successful business
and she lied and cheated and stole her
way
she's still doing it and now she's got
this successful job like helping young
people no
she doesn't get to do that
and I would just say man let the
self-righteousness Go Let It Go
that high school be high school thank
God I'm not judged on who I was in high
school
hopefully I've grown up a lot
hopefully I've been up a lot
maybe just maybe
[Music]
if somebody calls her out an appropriate
way she'll go you're right sorry
maybe she just needs to be removed from
that position
[Music]
or maybe
you can work real hard
set that brick down and just let her out
of life
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Florida and talk to the great and
wonderful Amy what's up Amy
hello Dr John well thank you for taking
my call thanks for calling hi
um I I feel kind of silly with this but
I want to thank you for taking my call
um my question you listen to the show
ever
I I have and I feel like my story is not
as dramatic as most of the ones you deal
with so I was surprised that Jenna
called me actually no we have to be
careful the show doesn't turn into Jerry
Springer so it's good just to have some
human some human stuff what's up yeah
this is human stuff um my question is
how do I cope with the anger and the
grief that I feel by being blindsided by
my own life
um that's what it okay well before I
start I just want to say there's no if
sins or buts I love my kids with all my
heart
I I I I know people are going to be
listening and they're going to be like
oh my gosh she's not thankful this is
one of my favorite ways people start now
listen okay he's great but okay with
this
all right
so my husband and I have been married um
21 years me too congratulations I know
how hard thank you personally that's a
long time congrats it is a long time and
it has been very hard but um we had two
kids
um in our early 20s uh that was all the
kids we were had planned to have we
thought you know we'll we'll have our
family we'll have our kids and you know
buy our mid to late 40s we'll be empty
nesting are you pregnant
no no okay oh God I'm not all right I
thought you were pregnant
so
um just as we were kind of leaving the
little kid fog you know where you never
see each other you you were just mad at
each other all the time uh the kids take
up everything
um we found out in our early 30s that we
were pregnant again
um so we had another kid
um kind of rolled with the punches there
and we're like okay well that just kind
of pushes things a little bit and uh
2020 rolled around and I remember
posting on Facebook how excited I was
because I was just feeling like I was
finally starting to feel me again
um I feel like myself you know I've been
a stay-at-home mom this whole time and
you just kind of get lost in it you feel
invisible you feel
like you don't exist and that you just
aren't even a real person anymore and um
I know that that lasts while the kids
are small and as they get older it kind
of goes away but anyway
2020 came I was about to turn 40 I
posted that on Facebook and a month
later I found out I was pregnant again
at 40. and from that moment I lost it I
immediately fell into like a deep grief
like grieving what I thought my 40s were
going to look like
okay I'm trying not to cry I'll cry away
dude
um listen you're right you're right
I I feel angry a lot that I had to start
over at 40. I feel angry that as my
older kids are transitioning that I
don't get to transition with them I feel
like I've been stuck at the starting
line for nearly 20 years and my friends
are all starting to empty nests and
going on trips with their husbands and
finally starting to live again
and I haven't been out to my dinner with
my husband in months we don't see each
other we have no time together we've
been living in a little kid fog for 20
years and
I'm just grieving so hard that I'm I'm
43 and it feels like I'm gonna be
invisible for another 20 years and I I
won't get to live until I'm 60 and I'm
just so
spent time emotionally like spent I'm
physically touched out I look in the
mirror and the person I see just keeps
getting older and I feel like my life
has just been stuck in the same season
for so long and I love my children with
all my heart but I don't love my life
and it fills me with guilt every morning
and grief and anger and I know it sounds
selfish but it feels like I don't exist
I feel like I have so much potential I
will never get to see the light of day
and I guess
I'm calling in just to sing say how do
you have any advice how to cope with
this yeah yeah
well one thank you for saying all that
out
loud yeah
yeah it helps have you ever said it all
out loud like that
I don't think so yeah
okay hey I'm proud of you okay I vomited
I promise what we do here that's that's
my job that's my job
um
I don't think for one second that you
don't like your kids
not for a second okay so I want to take
that completely off the table and
anybody you're Hey listen do not read
the YouTube comments because there's
there's gonna be morons that are posting
like oh my gosh I know don't read them
okay I know you promise yeah I promise I
know people that don't have kids are
going to be upset people who think I
don't appreciate them I do I love them
okay number two
getting pregnant with number four at 40
something
absolutely
is right to grieve what you thought was
about to be a whole new Tran a chapter
of your life
yeah 100 you had a picture painted
and it went away instantly
and you were faced with that I call it
like the the guilt shame teeter-totter
of
I don't want this oh great mom great mom
and then it smashes the other side and
you're like oh what a loser and then
it's like oh so yeah you got to get off
teeter-totter number one okay
um yeah so you're right you are right
and here's what I really want to
challenge you on though can I push back
on the whole I the whole model you've
created
yes please
you have fallen prey to one of the our
culture's most Insidious traps and lies
is what I would say
okay okay here's what it is
that there is some magical Finish Line
somewhere
it doesn't exist
yeah
and what that means is
right now is the life you are choosing
there are billions of people in the
world that don't have don't get choice
right I get that
me
most of the people that's in the show do
and when I say Choice it doesn't mean
like uh it's not like you're suddenly
gonna get a million dollars or suddenly
rent's gonna get cheaper it's not okay
when I say choice I mean
you keep waiting until this season X is
over so then you can start living your
life
and what your body is reacting to right
now is you are choosing consciously to
not live your life
there is a fog no question about it and
then there's a whole whole bunch of
choices
there is chaos with three kids
now a fourth and an infant are you
kidding me and there's a ton of choices
so I'm gonna challenge you because I
love you is that cool
yeah you and your husband have chosen to
not go on dates for months
you'll have chosen to have your sex life
just go away
you'll have chosen to take different
paths
and I have little kid I get how insane
it might sound
but my promise is this
if all of your kids were checking out
and you booked that first vacation and
you showed up at that first vacation
place
the worst part about that is you would
have gone with you
the person who felt like put her life on
hold for 20 something years
and I bet you didn't put it on hold as
much as you think you did
Maybe I'm Wrong
but I bet your kids love their mama
don't they
do and are your kids good kids the good
human beings
they are the treat people right
I think so
does your husband bathe with some
regularity
well that's questionable question
please don't fall into the Trap the only
contribution a person can make is some
sort of dollar amount in in a 401k
yeah yeah I know I just I I you've
created
and sustained
yeah I guess it's just um
I
I feel like my brain is wasted uh you
know like I on what I'm not making
reports in some law office
oh no I I don't think I would ever do
that but just what what did your brain
get wasted on
um
sitting down and playing Barbie dolls
and
stuff that I've done it day in and day
out
20 years already and I just you've
created a neuronal uh you've created
that's not even a word you've created
um
I'm trying to think of a non-nerd way to
say it
it's okay you can be a nerd I like that
kind of stuff
you've created brain maps for your kids
yeah
you've created their wiring
you've created their nervous system with
them co-created it with them
yeah you could build a residence hall at
a college or you could as an architect
or you can
I don't know build a small company
or you can build a human
yeah and they're all at various stages
mind-numbingly boring
insanely boring insanely frustrating
insanely rewarding
yeah but there's another story here
underneath this role you found yourself
in
is a woman who for whatever reason does
not like saying out loud what you need
and there's a woman who doesn't like
saying out loud you know what I really
want and fill in the blank
that's the part that I think has gone to
waste
is your voice
yeah
where did she go
you think she's been gone for a long
time I think you're right
yeah because it's always been
everybody else in the houses
is more important all of their needs are
more important
and I would tell you that's a curse of
modern parenting
because if if Mom's not well
you've got nothing to give if your
picture's not full you've got nothing to
pour into your kid's picture
that's how I feel right now it is
especially thinking about yeah
yeah but the the solution to being spent
is not a season of doing nothing
it's not a season of comparative
analysis watching your friends because I
promise you this I promise you
you're gonna have friends that go on a
couple of their vacations they're like
oh my gosh
and then they're gonna come over to your
house and your daughter's gonna crawl up
into your lap
right before she goes to bed and one of
them's gonna have a tear out on their
face and the other guy is going to be
tough and he's gonna go man I wish that
I missed that
okay everybody's wondering what it's
like on the other side of the fence
and the key to being well is being okay
with what side of the fence you happen
to be on
you're there you have a fourth kid how
old's your kid three oh yes I know three
yeah I I have four and
I can't change it I know that I think
I'm just trying to figure out how to how
to be okay with this I I don't I don't
want you to just be okay with it
yeah that's the thing I don't want to
just survive I want to thrive yes for a
long time so make the choice that Mom
goes first for a season will husband
allow a a wife with a voice
I hope so would he love no that's not a
good answer would he love a wife that
says here's what I need
I'm gonna try I don't know that he's
ever known me as that you know he's
always kind of been like the pants in
the family
so um I'm gonna speak up most men hold
on it's not just a matter of I'm just
gonna speak up because here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna not speak up
and then you're gonna explode on him and
he's gonna not know what hit him
yeah
most guys are so desperate to know why
their wife doesn't like them
oh I love him I know you do
but he can see his wife is miserable
yeah and if he's any husband worth a
crap he's wondering what it is about him
that's making that happen
yeah and that's a very selfish way to go
through the world we all do it right men
and women everybody goes to the world
going what about me what about me
but if you sat down and said over the
last 20 years I lost myself in my role
as a wife I lost myself in a role as a
mom and I put every single need in this
home before mine and I've just looked up
and I got nothing left in the tank
yeah
I want to figure out what I even need
I want to figure out what I even want
and I'm going to need you to help around
the house I'm gonna need you to help
with dinner I'm gonna need you to help
with like marriage Retreats who do we
want to become
because we're choosing not to sleep
together we're choosing to sleep in
separate rooms we're choosing all these
choices we're choosing to not go on
dates all these things are choices
and usually these conversations get
really hard
okay it won't be easy and stuff from the
past comes up new surprises will show up
all that
but this is a matter of you deciding
my voice matters in this house
I'm not just hired help
to let give my husband the life he wants
and to raise four kids
I have I'm a co-creator of this place
right
and if you hear nothing else today your
voice matters not only does it matter
it's really really important
that your kids get a vision
what a mom who takes care of herself
looks like
of a mom who says out loud I need this
and dude as a husband I'm so grateful
when my wife says hey I really need
today off even when I'm so frustrated by
it because I needed today off too
yeah we got back from a long vacation
recently and my wife said hey uh
I need
um me and my her two couple of her
girlfriends they're going out they do
this regularly we're going out all day
we're gonna we're just gonna figure out
where we're gonna go when we go
I just wanted I'd been on vacation for
two weeks with my kids I just needed
like my brain Clear
but dude I was so grateful that she said
what she needed out loud and she went
and they had a great time and I had a
blast with my kids I said to just change
the focus of the day
and actually thank goodness because we
had we had such a blast I mean me and my
little ones
I'd say that to tell you this
it's not just about speaking up it's
about taking your husband out and saying
the way we've chosen to do marriage up
until now
doesn't work anymore
I want to hear from you what kind of
marriage do you want to have I'm going
to speak up here's the kind of marriage
I want to have here's the kind of life I
want to have
here's the kind of kids and we're gonna
get babysitters because we're going out
and we're gonna go on vacation
and we're gonna drag the kid along
let's be fine we have a blast
kid can do what we can do they'll be
great or one of these older kids that
we've raised for 20 years can come back
and baby whatever we'll figure that out
but we're going to live the life we're
going to live and the kids are going to
be a part of that not the other way
around
the modern American house that revolves
around children is insane
the home should revolve around mom the
Revolt home should revolve around Dad
should we revolve around parents
not the other way around
I'm gonna send you a copy of my new book
building a non-anxious life I want you
guys to go through that book together
you and your husband I'll send it to you
for free I want you to do the exercises
it's about building a life that is
different now
life where everybody speaks up
everyone's heard everyone decides what
we're going to do everyone works
together
and most importantly
it's a house where we have peace
you're outside in that piece in a long
time that's because Mom has taken mom
like Amy's taking Amy and just shoved
her down
it's time for the world to meet Amy for
the first time
that starts at your at your dinner table
call anytime Amy we'll be with you every
step of the way this will get harder
before it gets easier okay
so get tough but you're worth so are
those little ones man
we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings in
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-in life today for just 20 bucks at
John deloney.com
all right we're back
um we were just talking offline the
movie's hot rod is at it what does he
say he's like what
we're in
it's uh say what and what way
so we're
with wh are awesome and Annie Sandberg
is the best of the best of the best
please bring back Brooklyn Nine-Nine
please
um but today's song of the day is by
hedis
[Laughter]
we just
Swedish dude a group of guys got in a
room and they're like dude we rock what
should we be called we should be called
devil dragons or I got one guys hedis
and they're like yeah okay we'll go with
weedus
Wheatus dude
the song is a shout out to our second
caller it's a Teenage Dirtbag and it
goes like this her name is Noel dude
Kelly if the person in this was named
Noel
that'd be incredible her name is Noel I
have a dream about her she Rings my bell
I got a gym I got gym class in half an
hour oh she rocks and kids and tube
socks this is going differently than I
thought but she doesn't know who I am
she doesn't care about me because I'm
just a Teenage Dirtbag baby listen to
Iron Maiden baby with me
I think there's a reason we didn't hear
a lot from Cletus after a Teenage
Dirtbag it's cool guys I like I'm Maiden
too
shout out Ryan holiday love you guys
stay in school don't do drugs bye
foreign